hey this weekend kicks off one of the
first major in-person events we've had
in almost a whole year john
that's right nearly 12 000 fans are
going to be up at the las vegas motor
speedway for cup racing nascar racing
three days of fun kate houston is
already there inside green flag in hand
with a look at how things are going to
be this weekend up there hey kate hi
kate
hey good morning yes tickets for this
weekend's events are
completely sold out now normally here at
the speedway they could seat about 80
000 people but due to health and safety
guidelines that's been
put down a little bit to 12 500 but you
know what nascar
and the speedway are doing a great job
making sure people can have fun in
person
as well as virtually online with a bunch
of different events there as well now i
am joined
by xfinity driver joe graf jr thank you
so much for being with us this morning
thank you so much for having me super
excited to be here yeah we're super
excited to have you in town now
you know tell me a little bit um about
how you're feeling ahead of your race
tomorrow um and how you're excited to be
back in las vegas
super excited to be back in las vegas
feeling really good
our uh [ __ ] up chevy camaro is going
to be fast uh
super excited to be out here [ __ ] up
sponsoring the truck race tonight so
really excited to come hang out at the
truck race with all of them
and watch some truck racing tonight and
then get after it tomorrow
yes absolutely now you know normally
drivers have some sort of fan
interactions it's a little different
this year but i'm sure it's exciting to
have fans back in the stands and how
will that impact you
it's awesome having fans back in the
stands it was super different last year
it just completely changes the energy
you feel right
we've had to find different ways to
interact with fans i've been doing a lot
of uh
zoom conferences with with random fans
throughout the year and things like that
just different ways to connect with them
because it's made it more difficult to
do so in person
sure sure and you know we have a lot of
fans here in las vegas so excited
to come to this weekend's events and
what would your message be to fans that
are
you know coming out here to support you
guys uh
first of all thank you this is this is
awesome this is all about the fans um
it's super excited to have them back
and uh just really really excited to be
racing in front of fans at las vegas for
the first time
in a while it'll be a lot of fun and uh
huge shout out to bucked up love what
they're doing here this weekend
and can't wait to get the racing
tomorrow yeah well i know fans are
really excited to be back here thank you
so much for joining us this morning
thank you for having me
now you can watch him tomorrow his race
kicks off at 1 30. the first race though
kicks off tonight
at 6 pm here at the las vegas motor
speedway reporting live keith houston 8
news now
it all leads up to the big race on
sunday as well kate thank you very much
and good luck to all the drivers this
weekend up at the speedway